you have a government and you also have
the people that are governed and in
previous videos we talked about this
idea of linkage institutions which are
institutions that connect the government
to the people and the people to the
government so people know what's going
on in the government and so that the
government knows the Preferences of the
people and examples of linkage
institutions let me just draw an arrow
here examples of linkage institutions
might be elections where the people are
able to communicate their preferences
parties where that could obviously
influence elections but also influence
policies you have various interest
groups but what we're going to focus on
in this video is the media now there's
one pure view of the media and sometimes
it's called the Fourth Estate where it
has a central role in government where
the goal is to hold the government
accountable to inform the people to have
this pure objective view of what is
going on with the government and bring
it to the people and then help the
people hold the government accountable
and also help the government know
objectively what the people are thinking
and that is an ideal that many in the
media may strive for but you have to
think about what are the incentives what
makes the media relevant and how do they
exist most media outlets are for-profit
organizations and so let me make a few
of these let's say that we have this one
right over here I'll call this media
outlet one let me do this one right over
here let's call this media outlet 2 as
for-profit organizations they need to
get revenue they need so they can get
their profits somehow and for most of
them it comes through ad revenue so
those ad dollars that are shown during
the news or during a TV show and so you
might guess that hey if I need to get ad
revenue advertisers aren't going to want
to show ads on a station that's not
getting any viewership so they're going
to say hey how do we get maximum
viewership one argument might be hey we
want to be the most objective high
quality news source and that is a
strategy that could be approached or
they could say hey maybe I could Kat
Kait
to certain belief systems to may be
left-leaning folks or right leading
folks if you were to say that this is
the distribution of people in our
population right over here where people
on this side lean left and then people
on the right side right over here lean
to the right
and these are people in between there
absolutely is a strategy where maybe if
you are this media outlet you say hey I
want to be centrist maybe give equal
time equal views to either side and
maybe I get that viewership but you
could also have a strategy as well what
if I want to capture all of these folks
well what they might want to hear is
something that's more critical of the
right that reinforces their but their
left beliefs and so I could cater to
that similarly you might have something
on the right saying I could capture all
of this audience here by helping to some
degree telling them what they want to
hear and maybe in some level reinforcing
their beliefs but by doing that I get a
large audience and I'm able to sell a
lot of ads it's an interesting debate
whether it is good or bad that you have
these media outlets that might cater to
certain ideologies but even if they are
they're still performing the role on
some level as a linkage institution
because these folks are trying to cater
and understand what their viewership
wants that is a signal to a government
that okay at least a demographic that
watches media station one this is the
kind of stuff that are thinking about
and the demographic that watches me to
station two these are the things that
they are thinking about so it does
communicate in some way to government
but you can imagine almost every media
outlet is trying to market that they are
that ideal objective and here's an
example of that where a media outlet is
actually reporting on how non objective
other media outlets are in their opinion
or perhaps in the opinion of their
viewers tonight a fair and balanced
examination of the mainstream media's
bias with three glaring new examples
first up Donald Trump is firing back at
the Washington Post after learning the
papers devoted an army of 20 staffers to
dig up dirt on every nook and cranny of
his life
now another dimension to appreciate how
the
eeeh as a linkage institution might
influence government or frankly might
influence other linkage institutions
like elections is how they report on
things remember they're trying to get
viewership because the viewership is
what makes the advertisers want to
advertise on their media outlets and so
to get viewership one strategy is to
make things really exciting make it look
like a sports competition make it look
like a horse race and you see this
especially during elections that
oftentimes the focus may not even be on
the substance it's really on who's
leading at a given time that can
sometimes influence the election and
give that person extra momentum
regardless of what their actual
positions are and here is an example of
that Hillary Clinton is extending her
lead over Donald Trump in several
national polls CNN is releasing a brand
new pull of polls which is an average of
the six last surveys and it shows Donald
Trump trailing Hillary Clinton by 10
points so how does he close that gap
Donald Trump's reached new heights in
the latest Fox News poll with 39% of
Republicans nationwide
he's more than doubling Ted Cruz at 18
Marco Rubio and ben Carson are virtually
tied for third within the polls margin
of error so the media definitely a very
important linkage institution in our
society but it's really interesting to
think about the various incentives for
it and that how that might influence its
actions as a linkage institution and how
its motivations might even affect other
linkage institutions like elections